And again, this is Dr. Cutters, you're at section 13 of the book stop by the cancer.
And in this section, it's going to be brief this little video because we're talking really about what integrative therapies are.
And I mentioned this throughout this entire program. So I don't need to speak a lot more about that.
So there's a difference between alternative and integrative.
And the difference is an alternative approach.
Maybe it's just by name only, but typically an alternative approach is I'm not going to do anything from my current oncologist to reject all that.
I'm going to go completely alternative approach. And that's fine. We have a lot of patients that make that choice.
An integrative approach is trying to take a step back and use as much wisdom as you possibly can.
So people will ask me, should I do chemo? Would you do chemo if it was me?
You know, I can't answer those questions. First of all, I believe that you need to ask God and seek wisdom and be obedient to the leads that God gives you.
Problem is that sometimes, you know, you may not be in that type of relationship with your Heavenly Father to be able to hear from him.
Number two, many times this relationship is clouded because of the state that you are currently in here in a state of fear.
Everybody around you is in a state of fear and it's very difficult to really know what to do and even seeking wisdom from as many sources as possible.
It's difficult to know what to do.
Now, I practice integrative that center, little logo is integrative cancer therapy. That is really my fellowship through the very good academy event of aging medicine.
It's an AMA fellowship and integrative cancer therapy, which means it's you really try to integrate the best of both worlds.
Is it is it's most of our patients either have done or currently doing some some traditional oncology.
And they're integrating some alternative approaches into it so that number one, they can get better results from their chemotherapy.
Number two, they can have less effects on the negative effects of their chemo or radiation or surgery.
And number three, it really stimulates a healing that the other approaches just do not do.
Chemo therapy may or may not do a good job of killing cancer cells, but it also does a wonderful job of killing good cells too.
So there's other things that you want to do. I always think it's wise to not be dogmatic.
It's absolutely ridiculously foolish for someone to say, I don't do alternative. I think that's crazy.
It makes no sense to me. There's no statistics behind it. You are you got your head in a hole.
But I think it's equally wrong to be so dogmatic the other way that I'm only going to go to my car practice or I'm going to go to my natural path.
And I will never go to a medical doctor ever. I don't believe it. That's equally wrong. I think God uses both approaches and you just have to be wise about it. I really think.
I really think that the alternative approach should be the standard approach. That's just me.
You should be trying to do things as natural as possible. And then you take the intervention of traditional care, which is currently traditional care standard medical care.
You so need it. That's my belief because ultimately my belief is to do what works. You know, if you do things the way you've always done them.
And that's the same thing with diet. You know, people will go, how long do I have to eat this way? Well, you know, eat the way you currently eat, got you where you are.
You know, it's time for a lifestyle change. We're so integrated in this country for a pill and a quick fix and I want to just take this pill and I want all my problems solved.
And I don't want to have to take any responsibility. Well, that's why our country is in the pickle that we are in politically, socially, financially, and everything is because nobody wants to take responsibility. Hello, we need to wake up.
You, you have cancer because of some reasons. And you need to take responsibility and go, OK, now I'm going to take a step back. I'm going to do some things different. I'm going to use wisdom. I'm going to seek counsel and I'm going to make the right choices.
If I'm just going to be willing to be a dumb sheep and be hurted into the medical establishment.
I hope you had luck with that because that's just not how we were called to live. So we need to be responsible with our life. So take a step back. Look at the big picture. It's easier to make a wiser decision.
Hope that helps understand that one.
And I will see you in section 14.